this is Jocko podcast number 189 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening and joining us
once again is Dave Burke good evening
Dave good evening and on the last two
podcasts Dave and I dug into the first
four chapters of the Marine Corps
doctrinal publications NC dp1 tack three
tactics so if you haven't listened to
those podcasts go start there and if you
have listened to them then we are diving
into chapter five you and I were talking
over the weekend about how you read
these in the basic school versus how you
read them now or how you read it this
time around yeah there's a pretty big
difference yeah there's a huge
difference I was saying when you asked
about how to read these and I read them
we got hand to them in a stack of pups
so all the Marine Corps manuals probably
a foot high stack of these white books
those little booklets and at the time it
was a chore I was like something I had
to do to pass a test I didn't look for
any real content I was looking for the
answers of the test and that was about
it it wasn't until I went back and
looked at him again
with a totally different set of eyes and
how man so many things I could have
learned if I actually read it
differently the first time there's I
mean I think it has to do when you can
overlay your own experience on it is
what makes it more makes the lessons
more obvious but these books are written
so clearly they're so straightforward
they're so clear so clear and and it's
it's it's amazing that the Marine Corps
can pull this off because normally you
would think to yourself okay if I told
you okay Dave you me and eight of our
friends are gonna write a book by
committee it would be a total nightmare
yep it would not come out good it would
be the most convoluted and confusing
thing ever and it'll be a total disaster
the Marine Corps somehow I would love to
go and I would love to see how they did
this I
love to see how they did this because
what I imagine had to have happened
there was one single human that had a
good grip on the vision and said okay
and everyone else this is the most
important part everyone else kind of
respected that vision and respected that
person yep I don't even know who that
person was they had to pull this off in
the Marine Corps they had to be someone
for lack of a better word they had to be
someone legit to be in there and say
okay listen you know we're leaving out
that section and not have everyone up in
arms and big debates yeah and you
couldn't have a bunch of guys that
wanted to put their little spin on it to
make it their own thing they wanted it
and in all eight chapters I guess
there's a tiny little bit of nuance and
some of me a little bit different but it
almost as if the same person I know it's
not one guy but if that's the same thing
all the way through the same theme and
there's not one chapter in there that is
oh this is too complex so this doesn't
really get to the point they're all
they're all the same
and what you described I've been in some
of those meetings not not to write a
publication everything is done by
committee you get five guys in a room
you do this and somebody defers to
somebody else but there's a vision on
this from the first word to the last
word that is throughout and it requires
actually people recognizing hey that
guy's idea is that work that's what
we're doing and everything gets gets
around and behind that yeah so not only
not only is it amazing the amount of
intelligence and knowledge that was in
the room but the amount of humility for
someone to listen to someone else say
hey I just wrote this part I just wrote
these three sentences and for someone
else to sit in the back of them and go
you know what
those are good leave them how they are
there's a massive amount of humility in
in writing this thing and putting this
thing together so let's go back to the
book chapter five chapter five is called
adapting
starts off with a couple quotes victory
smiles upon those who anticipate the
changes in the character of war not upon
those who wait to adapt themselves after
they occur hmm that's giulio douhet
which I'm sure I'm saying wrong some an
Italian an Italian general who is a
airpower
theorist you probably learned about him
in some somewhere along your course of
life yeah for sure
because he was early on he was thought
we're talking by plane get her power
that's what he was talking about air
power could break the will of the enemy
is kind of one of his one of his
theories which is true to a point to a
point to a point it's true
all right next quote in any problem
where an opposing force exists and
cannot be regulated one must foresee and
provide for alternative courses
adaptability is the law which governs
survival in wars as in life war being
but a concentrated form of the human
struggle against the environment hmm BH
Liddell Hart
so all those whatever whatever what's
one of my quote I have a call vote right
I'm quoting myself but I've said this
for a long time I think the quote is
well
combat reflects life only amplified and
intensified so BH Liddell Hart who's
British soldier World War one military
historian a very prolific military
theorist he said it even better than me
of course Wars a concentrated form of
the human struggle against the
environment so you have to be able to
adapt that's the name of this chapter
and here we go it kicks off the modern
battlefield is characterized by friction
uncertainty disorder and rapid change I
like working an environment that's
characterized by friction uncertainty
disorder and rapid
those are like the things that horrify
all human beings uncertainty everyone
hates that disorder at most people hate
that and rapid change everyone hates
that and that's what as a military human
that's what you've got to be that's what
you've got to be ready for that's what
you gotta train for and that's what you
got to be I for lack of order you gotta
learn to love that stuff yeah I mean
what in life that you do that matters
isn't characterized by those words
something that's actually important yeah
each situation is a unique combination
of shifting factors that cannot be
controlled with precision or certainty
this chapter discusses ways to think
about adapting or modifying our
decisions based on changed circumstances
or sudden opportunities a tactically
proficient leader must be able to adapt
actions to each situation the OODA loop
had discussed in Chapter four
essentially describes the process of
adaptation we observe the situation
orient to it decide what to do an act
the antagonist who can consistently
adapt more quickly to the situation will
have a significant advantage
adaptability is thus an important part
of marine corps tactics there's
something you don't think of every day
that adaptability is literally part of
marine corps tactics in essence
adaptability means shortening the time
it takes to adjust to each new situation
we see this with businesses all the time
businesses that either adapt and win or
don't adapt and lose yeah we see
businesses that they'll lay out a plan
not this big strategy this is how I see
things going and the ones that stick to
that and refuse to adjust and recognize
that that their environment is changing
they force themselves around that
initial plan and don't adjust they fail
and I the connection from combat to
business we make that connection all the
time and it's the exact same thing as
your plan is going to change your world
is going to change quickly and you
better adapt and if you can you'll be so
you'll be fine you'll be successful and
if you can't it's not gonna work if you
don't have humility you won't adapt
because you're gonna think that the way
you're doing it is fine yeah that's
that's the probably the biggest thing
that upholds people from adapting is
they're they're not there they're just
their egos so big that they're thinking
people aren't humble can't change period
because they think they've got
everything figured out that got
everything right and they don't change
and that's the recipe for failure it's
all throughout this book back to the
book there are two basic ways to adapt
sometimes we have enough situational
awareness to understand a situation in
advance and take prepare preparatory
action this is anticipation
at other times we have to adapt the
situation on the spur of the moment
without time for preparation this is
improvisation to be fully adaptable we
must be able to do both and this is one
of those things where I was listening to
was in a Jordan Peterson yesterday and
he was talking about how there's like
the creative people and then the other
side of the spectrum is about the
conscientious people and and most people
are either creative or their
conscientious conscientious meaning that
they'll do what they're told they'll do
it to the best of their ability their
very duty focused they're very reliable
the creative people obviously are like
none of those things I think and he was
saying creative people are poor yeah
that was this basic thing is if you're
creative you're not you're not building
a future you're not doing reliable
things on a disciplined basis and
occasionally you gets people that are
highly disciplined and creative and
their be successful sometimes you get
people that are highly creative and he
said there's this tiny percentage of
people that are wildly successful
creative people write some songwriter or
some artist some filmmaker that's and
oftentimes they're crazy you see this
with fighters to like a wildly creative
fighter they're there if they have their
that small percentage that they're gonna
be successful in fighting but a lot of
times they're the rest of their life is
not in good order right right it is not
in good order so I've said this that
your standard military guy girl whoever
if they are on the far end of
conscientious they'll be really really
good like oh yeah they're gonna get
promoted they're gonna do as they're
told they're gonna follow the orders and
there and there be good I'm not I'm not
saying that in a negative way at all
like they're squared away and it
awesome and they're great to work for
they want to do a good job but they get
like capped out at a certain point
because they don't have that spark of
creativity that they can look at a
rapidly changing situation I'd go I know
what we're gonna do so occasionally and
and and a lot of times those people that
are creative are too creative for the
military and they end up leaving because
they can't stand the constraints that
are put on them so you know even when
you read about people like Patton people
that were wildly successful they and
they also were they were they were
regimented and creative at the same time
so interesting dichotomy that you try to
have to kind of have to have or if you
really want to take it to the next level
back to the book anticipation the first
basic way to adapt is to anticipate by
which we mean to introduce new methods
schemes and techniques for future use in
order to anticipate we must be able to
forecast future actions at least to some
extent our forecasts are usually based
on past experiences often a forecast
involves considering what we learned
through trial and error in training
exercises or actual combat an excellent
example of anticipation is the marine
course development of amphibious warfare
techniques at Quantico
during the 1920s and 30s these
techniques proved to be essential to the
success in world war ii in both the
pacific and in europe all planning at
all excellence is a form of anticipatory
participation adaptation adapting our
actions in advance another important
tool for tactical adaptation is the use
of immediate action drills or standard
operating procedures right away was
called standard operating procedure
standing operating procedures you think
that's a misprint you think I'm a
misprint made it through the Marine
Corps it's always been standard as far
as I know so this is about the anything
that operating precise I think we have a
little misprint will will write to the
editor standard operating procedures
these are practice pre-designed generic
actions which cover common situations
having a collection of these tools
at our disposal allows us to react
immediately in a coordinated way to a
broad variety of tactical situations
immediate action drills do not replace
the need for tactical judgment they
merely provide a way to seize initiative
in the early stages of developing us of
a developing situation until we can take
more considered action they provide the
basis for adaptation very important to
have some good standard operating
procedures with martial arts in the
early nineties in the in the SEAL Teams
they were experimenting with a lot of
different martial arts and part of some
of the systems that they brought in was
they just had a standard immediate
action drill that you are going to go
through if X happened you are gonna
throw nine throat punches followed by a
kick to the groin followed by a face
rake they just and and if if you if you
did that if someone walks up to you in a
bar and shoves you and you deliver nine
punches to the throat face rate kick to
the groin like and people say yeah it
works
well you know what you're right that's
that's actually true if you have a
standard operating procedure that you're
gonna go to that's just hyper aggressive
in a street fight there's a decent
chance that's gonna work unfortunately
once that initial volley is over if
you're not ready to adapt to that person
that covers up grabs a hold or whatever
and starts the maneuver on you well then
you have a problem so there's a there's
a chance that's gonna work but you have
to be able to adapt afterwards same
thing in a firefight you know someone
starts shooting at you
we know the the Vietnam guys taught us
in a closed environment like the jungle
where there's no other friendly forces
around you're in a squad of see a squad
of SEALs of eight guys you get contacted
everyone drops down in their field of
fire and dumps a magazine
tilt was talking about that the
Frenchmen were talking about that they
would drop down man it was crazy hear
that story where he says they all dumped
their Maggs at the same time and then
there's silence as everyone's trying to
do a mag change that silence which
probably felt like 14 years was probably
probably three seconds it was probably
three seconds and and and but that's the
standard out same standard operating
procedures oh we just got contacted
we're gonna lay down some lead so you
get that really good aggressive
immediate action drill then you have to
be able to learn how to think and that's
where some of those early martial arts
systems they succeeded in that initial
volley and then the adaptation piece if
it went beyond that we're talking
mission failure we used to teach at Top
Gun I talked about this a lot when we
would have you'd have a tactical
situation SOPs for free rations when you
didn't know what to do so if you looked
at a situation and didn't really
understand what you should do you still
have to do something going wins level
and flying straight ahead is a death
sentence
so our SOP for a reaction to being shot
at was what we called lift vector on and
pull basically means point of the guy
pull as hard as you can what's Paul do
Paul closes the distance between the two
views and moves the airplane from the
piece of sky that you're in to some
other piece of sky and makes the closure
happen as fast as you can to try to
minimize the distance what you're trying
to create a separation so I get
separation from you I can attack you and
I if I'm the defender I want to close
that separation and bring that fight
down as close as I can but the reality
is that me putting my lift vector on and
pulling towards you isn't the right
answer what I actually needed to do is
figure out I apply that SOP and as soon
as I do that I need to engage my brain
to think okay now where do I need to
really go which is maybe up an actress
or some other reaction the SOP in an
airplane was that maneuver which is no
different than dump your mag it was to
close the gap of time till you actually
figured out what's going on what's the
situation and that's the adaptation
you're talking about the SOP really was
just a gap filler until you could get
your brain engaged to doing the right
thing so you want to close the distance
on the enemy you want to get closer to
them yeah so if I am let's say you and I
are across from each other and you're
shooting you're gonna shoot at me and I
see that you're in a position to employ
a weapon against me I actually want to
close the distance between you and me as
fast as I can to get inside your weapons
range as quickly as possible cuz if I
extend away from that or do nothing you
get more opportunity to get to a more
advantageous position but me pulling
directly towards you isn't the right
answer I don't know what the right if I
knew what the right answer was I
wouldn't be here in the first place
so my SOP is
have to close the distance right away
and the good pilots the amount of time
with sometimes would take a half a
second for they adjust that manoeuvre
but that immediate action that SOP is
lift vector on a pole in an airplane
would you ever be able to be ahead of
your SOP in other words yeah you're
laughing like I'm in yeah no no I guess
I think you know the answer depending on
who you're fighting if I'm fighting
someone who is not as experienced and
hasn't seen this before and doesn't have
that rolodex of can't anticipate cuz he
hasn't seen it
I'm never reacting I'm never reacting to
what he's doing I'm always not just that
in front of him I'm moves out in front
of him but if I was fighting against a
guy who was at my level or better there
are times he would do things that I had
to react to and the timeframe that takes
me to react to an SOP to the right thing
the short of that timeframe the more
likely is I'm gonna be successful and if
I don't know what to do and I just spend
the entire fight lift vector on and pull
I'm gonna lose and that SOP was
something that eventually you actually
got passed and almost never had to do it
because you weren't there in the first
place you were thinking moves ahead and
get there yeah so that's that's a good
thing to think about too and it's a good
thing to think about from a self defense
perspective martial arts wise like you
should have some standard operating
procedures some immediate action drills
that you're gonna do that are just gonna
get you and you know closing the
distance for a jujitsu guy is real
instinctive if you watched the UFC or
whatever a wrestler want or jujitsu guy
once they start getting banged up and
they don't really know what to do their
instincts take over and they just shoot
and close the distance and try and get
in that's not always the best thing in a
in a street fight in fact it often isn't
what we want to do is break contact so
you know think about that think about
that with your jiu-jitsu coach your
martial arts instructor what is your
move gonna do what's your what's your
immediate action drill when someone gets
in your face when someone grabs you how
are you gonna break contact and get away
have a good SOP and a good immediate
action drill for that alright same thing
with boxing by the way and you know when
you see a guy in trouble in boxing you
know like try to hug them even though
necessarily the boxer hard but oh yeah
that's the thing to get them out of
trouble
yeah so he can how you say like you
wanna gives in your brain and you you
actually want to get inside the range of
their weapons
yeah a boy died that doesn't work quite
as well cuz you get inside and you're
getting elbowed in the face or you're
getting on need and the ribs no good you
caught a need to the rib before yes sir
yeah that's not fun
no it's not you don't even when you're
watching a mai tai fight because they're
so hardcore yeah they get needing the
rib and you think well that must not
hurt real bad yeah well here's the thing
it in Muay Thai this is an actual like
thing you can't show when you you get
hurt right like you can get hit in the
legs legs suck stupid oh yeah yeah
there's anything in the ribs understand
but yeah that need the oh yeah that's
bad but you can't show pain in wheat I
like literally that's kind of the rule
like if you show pain it's like you
fundamentally didn't follow the protocol
you know you see them saying it's like
an official thing because when they see
the pain they're just gonna go if you go
oh dang that leg kick hurt even if you
just go like this go or even limp on or
a second UFC and you smile yes you're
like oh no that didn't hurt everyone oh
yes and you see the leg kicks just keep
coming like dang they taking like even
more leg kicks to that same leg every
time it's like that's the SOP you see
the little pain on the guy's face
whatever you just keep hitting that
thing yeah there's another SOP in
Thailand that I learned about well it's
maybe it's not in Thailand but it's
definitely with Thai food in America
every Thai food yes sir alright so I get
you know I I will up the lever of spice
1 to 10 at the Thai restaurant that I go
to and over a year I went you know from
five to seven to nine one time I went in
there and nine you know no factor 8 no
factor like taste good thing I went in
there one time and he said well what
type of spice would you like today sir
and I said 10
they made me something that was psycho
like it was almost inedible
I ate it just out of sheer ego yeah ego
I just ate it but I would my mouth was
on fire and so the waitress like when I
ordered it she kind of looked at me like
this is not a good move but I didn't
what I didn't realize so then the next
time I came I said hey last time I came
you know I asked for 10 I don't want 10
again
I said when I asked for ten is that like
an insult slash challenge to the kitchen
yeah and she said oh yes so so don't
order ten unless you want your face to
be on fire and then that makes sense too
because when you're over here like nine
no factor you know ten should be
incrementally should be consistent you
say yeah yeah yeah yeah so the way nine
was ten should have been a little bit
more right to the difference between
eight and nine or even at least
establish some sort of a pattern you see
saying like if the increment between
eight and nine it's like a four maybe
nine and ten is like eight okay I dig it
but that's all that fell long that's
that's the that in Thailand they call
the foreigners following it means I
think it means foreign yeah there are
oily or just does not say super positive
but no it's it's it's cuz you know when
you go to Thailand and the followings go
to they the the full-on like a drunk
European dude says I'll fight that
little Thai guy put me in the ring with
him and they go okay gotcha
and they put the big German dude in
there or whatever who's not a fighter
he's just a guy who's two hundred and
238 pounds of beer and they put him in
there against a 142 pounds Thai kid that
just hacks him apart with with leg kicks
and he just denial AIT's him
so anyways feel that we can move at the
Thai restaurant only two pieces not with
leg kicks but with whatever spice they
put it there
so use caution back to the book
improvisation so this is the other form
the second basic way to adapt is to
improvise to adjust to a situation on
the spur of the moment without any
preparation like anticipation
improvisation is the key to maneuver is
key to maneuver warfare improvisation
requires creative intelligence
intelligent and experienced leaders who
have an intuition a pre intuitive
appreciation for what will work and what
will not improvisation is of critical
importance to increasing speed it
requires commanders who
his strong situational awareness and the
firm understanding of their senior
commanders intent so they can adjust
their own actions in accordance with the
higher commanders desires often we will
find ourselves in a situation to where
our organic resources weapons vehicles
and so on are not adequate to keep us
moving fast in France 1940 German
general Heinz Gideon put some of his
infantry in commandeered French buses on
Grenada when Army Rangers needed
vehicles they took East German trucks
belonging to the Grenadian army sound
unorthodox there is nothing Orthodox
about failure due to an inability to
adapt improvisation and this is one of
those ones where you this is where you
start to see a leader that can't that
doesn't have the creative aspect to his
thought process this is where you see
when then when the situation demands
true improvisation this is where you see
a little crack in the in the armor of
the highly conscientious conscientious
leader yeah that's the guy you're
talking about before and both of these
things should realize that these are
both learned things the ability to
anticipate is not just some sort of
magical vision that you're born with
it's they talk about reps over and over
again but even this idea of improvising
it's what the what has learned there is
a recognition is hey my skill set here
my bag of tricks I don't have what I
need to actually make happen what I need
to have happen I understand the intent
and I don't have the resources at hand
so I actually need to recognize this is
the time to improvise and it's that
rigid conscientious thinking that
doesn't allow you to see you know what I
need and it's not just totally winging
it it's not just on the fly it's
recognizing I need to come up with a
creative solution here because what I
have available doesn't work and those
rigid leaders and I know who you're
talking I've seen them throughout my
career they simply don't have that place
where they can go and you have to when
at times that are most critical you have
to be able to go there and the good
leaders that's the creative piece that
they need to be to put tap into it in a
career you know what I notice is you if
you can't detach from the situation you
won't be able to be creative when I'm
looking at a problem I sometimes have to
consciously detach from the situation
and take a different look at it because
what you will see we all we all are kind
of brainwashed into just pattern
recognition and then applying the
appropriate known tested solution but
when you look at something you don't
really see a pattern what you do is you
try and apply a pattern that you've seen
in the past and that's a positive thing
that makes this but sometimes that
pattern is just too far off it's just
not quite there and all you'll do is try
and apply the the prescription that you
have to that problem and it's not gonna
work out and for me when I see a problem
I always have to say okay take a step
back and look at this from a different
angle because if you don't do that if
you don't do that you're not gonna see
how far off your pattern recognition
actually is and it can be far off yeah
and sometimes to that pattern
recognition that is a good thing like
you described tells you oh I need I need
this I need air support here I need
heavy machineguns here okay I have this
the answer it's like well guess what you
don't have that resource today that
thing that you say you need it doesn't
exist so so what are you gonna do now
and that's when you see you can see
people panic in those situations because
they don't think there's a solution
available to them and the reality is
there is if you can do what you just
described but they think pattern
recognition situation dictates this is
what I use and if that tool that they
are used to having doesn't exist for
them there that's when they panic and
that's when that's the worst-case
situation for them as they don't think
there's an out you can actually surround
yourself with people that can help you
there you know if you can actually have
other people say hey I saw this on our
way in I think there's a solution here
and that's where the humility piece
requires is hey what do you see yeah I
see this and somebody else can actually
lead you down that road
instead of just refusing the budge from
your position and setting your whole
team up to fail not a good plan no
improvisation in which Marines of the
2nd battalion 5th Marine Regiment found
themselves in the Battle of whey City
Republic of Vietnam in February of 1968
one of their first objectives was to
retake the city's treasury building
which was heavily defended by the North
Vietnamese prior to the assault the
Marines were disappointed to see that
their mortar fire was having little
effect on the building or its defenders
then the executive officer found some us
tear tear gas canisters and dispensers
in the military assistance compound they
had reoccupied realizing the North
Vietnamese lacked gas masks the Marines
proceeded to lob to your gas canisters
into the Treasury Building as a result
of the executive officers quick thinking
and adaptation the North Vietnamese
quickly vacated the building and the
Marines secured the objective with
minimal casualties that seems real
obvious when you're looking back at it
but this is one of those situations
where exactly what you were just talking
about if you yeah I could and I I would
say you can watch and I have watched
many military leaders in that exact
situation when I was running training I
saw all the time these guys would they
know what the standard operating
procedure is and they would just stick
with it I would I would give all kinds
of answers would be floating around the
battlefield for him and they wouldn't
see them until you learn to take a step
back so this is a great example and it
seems so obvious but it's not that
obvious when you're in the situation and
when you're emotional about the
situation yeah it's really hard to see
that when you're emotional
back to the book flexible plans we have
several techniques to help us develop
adaptability one of these is to make
flexible plans flexible flexible
flexible plans can enhance adaptability
by establishing a course of action that
provides for multiple options for
example a blocking position that covers
two avenues of approach from the same
location instead of only one provides
the flexibility to adapt to an enemy
coming through either Avenue
we can increase our flexibility by
providing branches for current and
future operations and those are like
little branch plans that just branch off
of on the main plan branches are options
ie changing disposition orientation
strength movement or accepting or
declining battle to deal with changing
conditions on the battlefield that may
affect the plan flexibility can also be
increased by providing sequels for the
current and future operation sequels are
courses of action to follow probable
battle or engagement outcomes victory
defeat or stalemate I have a note here
that I wrote to myself and the note that
I wrote to myself it says it's okay and
I put these in quotes it's okay then we
will do something else effective that
moves us toward our goal that's that's
like such a good answer
oh we've we've we've we've become
stagnant it's okay like think about that
from a from your in a leadership
position or no think of it from a
subordinate position you've hit a wall
and you can't get through and you look
at your leader and your leader says it's
okay we're gonna do something else
that's gonna be effective that's gonna
move us toward our goal oh and that
seems it's really easy to look at these
things and say well that's real obvious
I'm telling you it is not obvious unless
you train yourself to start thinking
that way it is not obvious there's a
reason that's in this book it's in this
book because it's hard as simple as that
sounds build a plan and have a whole
bunch of options available to you when
your plan doesn't work that's written
down in the marine corps tactics manual
specifically because they know how hard
this is especially in combat yeah back
to the book the value of branches and
sequels is that they prepare us for
several different actions we should keep
the number of branches and sequels to a
relative few and and Lafe and I talked
about that in the dichotomy leadership
where people go okay you want to see
plans I got some branch plants and they
create 50 of them you need three yeah
you need to you need for you don't need
fifty back to the book we should not try
to develop so many branches in sequels
that we cannot adequately plan train and
or prepare for them for any of them and
what I found even on top of that is when
you have multiple branches and you
rehearse them all no one knows what's
actually happening you know if you
rehearse you rehearse your primary this
is what you should do you should
rehearse your primary one like ten times
your secondary one three times and your
tertiary one once as a walkthrough yeah
and you should do them in Reverse or
order or at least maybe not reverse
order
but you practice your primary one five
times three times on your secondary one
time on your tertiary five more times on
your privates on that that's where you
want them to the guys to come out the
gate on but otherwise you're gonna get
half the guys do it one and half the
guys doing something else it's a
nightmare
back to the book this skillful
well-thought-out use of branches and
sequels becomes an important means of
anticipating future courses of action
this anticipation helps accelerate the
decision cycle and therefore increases
the temple this idea of anticipation I
mean what you're saying is that I know
what the enemy is going to do and when
you're doing jujitsu and you're good at
jujitsu I used to describe to Jitsu and
I used to say when you're good at
jujitsu you can see the future like if I
roll with you Dave because I've been
training for a long time there's a 90%
chance that I know what you're about to
do like when you were going up against a
Top Gun student that had just showed up
there's an i twelve you tell me no right
if there's like a 90% chance that this
guy's gonna be when I do this he's gonna
do that there's a there so so this idea
that you begin to be able to predict
what the future holds is think about it
think about that's that's what happens
in jujitsu
that's what happens in jujitsu that's
what makes you get beat in jujitsu is
the person you're going against knows
what you're going to do and is waiting
there
for you to do it and submit you that's
what happens with tactics if you can
anticipate what the enemy is going to do
you can be waiting for them and we used
to set operations up like that hey when
we set the breach here that's gonna
drive people in this direction out of
the building if they try to escape
thinking about this back door this back
window boom we'll be waiting right there
for them or whatever like that's how we
do it so this idea of anticipation man
if you can if you can dedicate a little
bit of time to think about what your
competitor what the enemy is going to do
you're gonna set yourself up for a
what's the videogame term echo Charles
for like a total is it total victory you
flawlessly flawless victory I knew there
was a better term thank you welcome glad
you're back from Hawaii to give us this
information I never would have known
that answer yes well done flexible plans
avoid unnecessary detail that not only
consumes time in their development but
has a tendency to restrict subordinates
latitude how often do we see the the
leader that thinks that the more detail
they put into a plan the better off
they're gonna be and the better people
are gonna understand it all the time
that comment about your subordinates
latitude the goal should actually be is
to tell them what to do the least amount
of time and give them the most latitude
possible that should be your goal to let
them figure out what it is you're going
to do that comment that latitude comment
is something I thought that's so
critical for leaders give your folks
latitude to do that I like the way they
just call it unnecessary detail and this
is one of those things were in the
military the American attitude of life
is if a little is good then more is
better and if more is better than just
max it out to the nth degree and I saw
that over and over again and we've wrote
about it an extreme ownership the
planning it's like life and Seth were so
used to these 200 PowerPoint slide
briefs and I was telling him look we're
not doing that put a map up on the wall
talk to guys
Lafe and Seth were actually scared for
their careers when the commanding
officer was coming up to to sit in on
their briefs they were worried about
what was gonna happen to their careers
because they wanted to build 200
PowerPoint slides for a brief on a on a
reconnaissance in the woods that's what
they wanted to do so what they realized
is that all that detail all that use
they've been driven they thought you
know that's somewhere along the line in
the in the seal community someone said
oh well you put some good detail in
there put more and then a year later
someone else is saying put more and then
a year later someone put more and that's
how you end up with 200 slides that no
one understands yeah totally ridiculous
back to the book instead flexible plans
lay out what needs to be accomplished
but leave the manner of accomplishment
to subordinates which is what you just
said this allows subordinates the
flexibility to deal with a broader range
of circumstances flexible plans are
plans that can be easily changed plans
that require coordination are said to be
coupled if all parts of a plan are too
tightly coupled the plan is harder to
change because changing any one part of
the plan means changing all the other
parts instead we should try and develop
modular loosely connected plans then if
we change or modify any one part of the
plan it does not directly affect all the
other parts this is why I talked about a
little bit on one of our earlier
podcasts from this book is I would try
and keep my unit integrity my fireteam
integrity together as much as I could so
that way if something changed it was
really easy just to say ok for our teams
2 & 3 you're doing this now and not
putting little special teams together
for every people like to put together
little special teams for everything no
use the team use the team that's used to
working with each other
finally flexible plans should be simple
plans simple plans are easier to adapt
to the rapidly changing complex and
fluid situations that we experience in
combat I mean the the idea that keeping
the idea of keeping your plans simple
you know when I would be going through
training when I would be getting judged
by the training cadre that was such a
big advantage for me this be like oh
yeah this is what we're gonna do guys
we're gonna get online here we're gonna
move through the target we're gonna stay
in fireteam integrity once one of the
other side of the target will cause like
these basic plants that it didn't matter
what we encountered on the target every
it was it was almost like I was cheating
it was almost like I was cheating and
you know what what you know what they do
they lure you in to coming up with a
complex button they go hey Jocko we're
gonna give you guys all day today to
plan this and they they think you're
they're doing you a favor and they're
thinking that that when you come up with
a more complex plan that it's gonna be
better to actually think that and I'd
say okay cool I'm still gonna plan it in
13 minutes and once we get the plan done
you know okay well I had some detail to
it but the essential plant 13 minutes
nine minutes let me look at the target
for nine minutes and I'm gonna tell you
exactly how this thing's gonna go down
and the simplicity that you keep such a
huge advantage over it's cheating it's
almost cheating it is we talked about
this in business all the time this this
idea of simples one of the laws that we
talked about it and I'll ask the
question that I'll have key leaders
that'll bring us in and we'll look at
them and I'll say simply hey why is it
important for the plan to be simple
enough that everybody on your team
especially at the lowest level of your
team understands it and they won't
really know the answer and they'll think
well it helps the reason you want
everybody to understand the plan at the
lowest level is that those are people
gonna be out there doing the real work
they're the ones that are actually doing
the work not you as the Keely or not and
if they don't understand what to do the
simple thing is that they they won't
know what to do and you'll be stuck
solving all the problems all day and
that's what we see these leaders I'm
constantly answering questions from all
my people it's like because they don't
know what to do and they're not the
point of friction and if your plan was
actually less complex it would help
and they think no I need to give them
more details more that's actually not
but not what they need they need to just
understand what you're trying to get
accomplished and let them do the work
how it can be counter into this it can
be counterintuitive because someone will
see their subordinates go out to do
something and they miss the mark yeah
and so what they do is they try and
drive more detailed oh now look there's
a there's obviously a dichotomy this and
there's an encounter to where you're not
giving them enough information and they
don't understand what's going on they
don't understand what the objective is
that that that can't happen it usually
happens the other way though totally
next section in this book is called
decentralization another excellent way
to improve adaptability is to
decentralize decision making Authority
as much as each situation allows this
means that commanders on the scene and
closest to the events have the latitude
to deal with the situation as required
on their own authority but always in
accordance with the higher commander's
intent this decentralization
decentralization speeds up reaction time
we don't have to wait for information to
flow up to a higher command and orders
to flow back down
it increases responsiveness of the
organization which in turn increases
adaptability decentralizing control
through the use of mission orders is one
of the tools we use to maximize our
ability to adapt and this is the fourth
law of combat decentralized command
consume ordinates plays an important
part in decentralization leaders who
have confidence in the capabilities of
their subordinates will feel more
comfortable in granting them greater
latitude in accomplishing tasks so
that's what you have to do you have to
build up that confidence in your
subordinates and once you have
confidence in your support and so you
can let them run you can get out of
their way actually and for them to be
confident in themselves as well if they
can actually actually do that
understanding the big intent and that
they can do that in themselves that this
book is making this manual is making the
connection between the need to be
creative and the need to let your people
be creative and centralization and
giving them too much
till two actually stifles the thing you
need from them the most which is
creativity and latitude when they're at
the point of friction which you can't be
as a leader all the time with them
they're gonna be there on their own
more often than not and you actually
have to cultivate that well in advance
or they are going to freeze and they're
gonna they can have too much friction
they won't know what to do when it
matters the most and you won't be able
to help them I'm sure you saw that all
the time as a mission lead at Top Gun
I'd have six different elements dealing
with six different problems and I
couldn't be usually not at any of them
maybe I could be with one if I was it
happened to be at the right place at the
right time in my airplane but if
something happened critical 6070 miles
away i I can't influence that I can't
help them with that this idea of
creativity that's the confidence that
they're talking about in them being able
to solve their own problems and when you
see it as a leader that's when it allows
you to step back it's awesome to watch
when leaders figure that out oh you just
you train them and just let them do
their job and it worked out how'd that
make you feel it's awesome some
pragmatic kind of tactical level talk
here if you have your subordinates and
they don't accomplish the mission the
way they should or they make some bad
decisions and your instinct is okay what
I need to do is give them more detailed
commands well that that's not the right
answer so what is the right answer
the right answer is what you want to do
is you need to make sure that they
understand what your commander's intent
was you need to make sure that you've
given them the training so that they
learn to recognize patterns you need to
make sure you go give them the training
so that they so that they learn that
part of creativity you need to make sure
that they understand that what you want
them to do out on the battlefield is to
actually lead because a lot of times
people don't understand that they what
they think they should do is wait for
you to tell them what to do yeah that's
the breakdown so the it's one of those
moments where you need to look when your
team doesn't do what you want them to do
and your instinct is I need to tell them
what to do more that's the wrong
instinct what you need to do it's not
that you need to just let them do
whatever they want because they've
already proved they just proved that
they don't know how to do that but what
you need to do now is you need to train
them to think you need to train them to
be creative you need to train them to
to follow up their immediate action
drills and their standard operating
procedures with an actual assessment of
what is really happening and make some
decisions based on what they've been
trained to do what the commander's
intent is what the survivability of the
mission is like all those things they
have to learn to think and I got to see
this over and over again in my
leadership laboratory running the West
Coast SEAL training I got to see it over
and over again you could see someone in
their first block of training in in unit
level training their first block of
training you would see a young seal
leader who would completely lock up
mental lock up when things started going
sideways and believe me they would go
sideways mental lock up then you fast
forward I'd go out to the next block of
training all of a sudden you see oh a
little spark a little something a little
maybe a little decision a hesitant
decision but a decision you go out to
the last block of training
something's something it hasn't even
gone wrong yet it is beginning to go
wrong and they go hey will you do
assault that building right now and you
go okay this guy this person's got it so
you can absolutely get better at this
but the way you do it is not by
providing more direction it's actually
by providing the proper training because
it's not nothing and that's what I want
to the point I want to make is it's not
when I say hey if your team isn't doing
what you want to do give them less
direction
that's not the answer it the answer is
given less direction and give them the
training give them the mindset given the
authority give them the repetitions give
them the pattern-recognition give them
the standard operating procedure and the
immediate action drill and I've talked
about this before part of the immediate
action drill that you need to have is
what you're gonna do when you don't know
what's going on because there's a
process that you can follow when you
don't know what is happening what you
need to do if I start getting shot at
and I don't know what's happening okay
what am I gonna do am I gonna start em I
got reload another magazine and shoot it
no I'm absolutely not gonna do that I'm
gonna take a step back I'm gonna get off
the firing line I'm gonna high pour my
weapon I'm gonna look to my left I'm
gonna look to my right I'm gonna assess
where my guys are and make sure I know
that then I'm gonna start assessing
where the enemy is once I've done that
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna make
the little
littlest move that I can possibly make
that's gonna move me in the direction
that I suspect is the right way to go so
I'm gonna make one small movement that I
think is right I'm not gonna commit to
it a hundred percent but I'm gonna make
one small movement once we made that one
small movement and it proves that maybe
I'm I was right in my suspicions cool
now I'll make a bolder movement and
we'll continue in that direction but you
can do that you can develop a standard
operating procedure an immediate action
drill of what to do when you don't know
what to do so when you were in an
aircraft and you got shot at by the
enemy and you did your immediate action
drill which was turned towards them then
what's your next what's the next steps
that you take so you don't know what's
happening you do your immediate action
drill so you had to have some kind of
thing that you did I mean you already
said it earlier you start looking around
figuring out what you're gonna do next
it's that's funny because as you as you
were going what you just described I was
thinking about Top Gun I started
thinking about jujitsu I was thinking
about our time in Ramadi I was thinking
about business all that that thing you
just described that template fits in all
those different places at the same time
and it's it's really how I was
describing that that immediate action
response that SOP was do this until you
figure out what you're supposed to do
you you said something you said it twice
people can learn to be creative I have
had people work with me and say I'm not
a very creative person I'm better at
this so have an Operations Officer I'm
not a real creative lit thinker I think
like you know I'm a written immediately
put that person in a position where he's
uncomfortable not so much that he can
make a mistake that's gonna be
catastrophic for the squadron
I wouldn't put him in a situation that
is so far out of his comfort zone that
he could make a decision that will hurt
the team so bad that it's not
recoverable but you describe it people
can learn and have to learn how to be
creative and the the really short answer
is what do i do once I get past that
initial move is I think that's creative
I look at and think what do I need to do
I take all those different pieces
together the more experienced I am the
easier it is and I figure out okay I
need to stop this this has been a good
intermediate answer but it's not the
right answer
and now I need to move in this other
direction or pull in some other resource
tell another airplane what's going on
call around you
ever that answer is the answer is
different every single time the answer
is actually think them and you talked
about situational awareness to the more
you know what's going around you what
the easiest easier the answer is and the
only way to get situational awareness is
to put yourself in those situations over
and over and over again so you can
anticipate what you need to do the idea
for me is and for you it's what you just
described as well well I think you just
described as is you're going immediately
back into the loop to orient yourself to
what's going on decide what you're going
to do next and act but that orient piece
that you're once you've made your
initial immediate action drill okay cool
your immediate that's act right you just
did an action and now what are you gonna
do you're gonna orient yourself to where
you are now which is gonna look around
for me taking a step back going to high
port and looking around if you if I
could get a young leader to do that if I
could get a young leader to do that it
was like I took them from from having a
garbage can over their head to standing
on a mountaintop with thermal vision
that's what it seemed like because when
you are wrapped up in that situation you
cannot see anything you might as well
have a garbage can over your head if the
minute you take a step back you can see
everything so once I could get someone
to make that little transition and
sometimes it was pretty easy sometimes
it was pretty hard you know we we many
times gave the young leaders you know
stick guns that didn't shoot and here
you go man I'm telling you you cannot be
shooting this thing what you need to do
is be looking around but once you make
that trip that's like these so so for me
the immediate action drill for the bdd
action drill for I don't know what's
happening is step back turn my head
physically look around and assess what's
happening and then make the the smallest
move I can possibly make towards the
direction I suspect is correct the
beauty of what you just said is the
immediate action and an airplane that I
described earlier that lift that crown
and pull that's what allows you
to stick to take a step back and think
because that maneuver that movement
requires no brain power you just turn
the airplane and pull back in the stick
it's like the first thing you ever
learned to do and that's what allows you
to look around and see what's happening
we would do these training missions and
we record everything cameras over your
shoulder cameras in the front of the
plane the cranes are everywhere and the
radar screen is on the right side of
almost every Jedi flew it's over on the
right side and you would see guys heads
to the point that their nose is almost
on the screen and they were staring at
the one thing that thought was the most
important thing and and literally not
looking not looking or and so it's no
different than being on the line your
fixation its target fixation it's it's
looking down the side of your weapon and
if you took just take your take stick us
you can't take a setback in air place
you could just lift your head just lift
your head up and look around what would
you is that what you would tell the
young pilot litter of those words yeah
and I'd say do you see your head in the
reflection you see your helmet where is
it because it goes it's literally
touching the radar and all the pilots
that are listening this or in our
laughing cuz they know what that looks
like when your nose is on the screen
because you're staring at it you don't
see anything else is going on that
immediate action drill is a move that
requires no real brain it doesn't
require to you to do anything other than
the maneuver and during that time is
when you take a step back you look
around the big picture and then you make
a decision I mean this is what I
actually wrote on Seth Stone's Humvee
window in front of his face tensile yea
with grease pencil Iroh man step number
wise said listen man that's what you're
gonna do step number one relax step
number two look around step number three
make a call as soon as he the next run
he'd followed those instructions and
that's examiner yeah for four Oh instead
of just staring at like the targets that
just popped up down range or the where
your guys rounds were impacting like no
just take us just relax
look around and make a call so when you
had a really good pilot with their head
just be constantly just all looking all
around :
yeah all the time they never stop moving
they never stop looking around and they
talk very little they don't save
very much they're just and at some
interval they make one call sweet one to
flow north and all of a sudden there's a
whole formation which and because they
would see whatever is happening and he
can make these massive amount of
influences into what's going to fight by
talking less than everybody else because
he's spending 90% of the time just
watching and go there's some friction
and creating over here nobody's
responding to it I'm gonna get my guys
summing over the way I was just attached
sitting up at altitude mentally and
going okay we're gonna take a step back
and oh this is what we're gonna do now
and that's why as a mission commander
you know we talk about you know dog
fighting against an another aircraft and
how fun that is and how much you it's
the last thing I really wanted to be
doing as a leader that's no different
than being in hand-to-hand combat when
you're trying to lead your battalion it
seems like a lot of fun and and don't
get me wrong if the opportunity if you
had to do it you do it that's required
of course you do that but really the
best leaders in an airplane were the
ones that shot the least said the least
saw the most and made the right calls
and right influence because they were
too attached the whole time and this is
completely reinforced by the fact that
the American fighters in Korea one of
the biggest assets that they had was
they had the clear [__] that's exactly
right yep like that made the you know
you think oh yeah I'm sure that makes it
deal no you don't get what a big deal
that makes they all had perfect vision
and and they could see more than the
enemy could see that was the
difference-maker it certainly wasn't how
good the machine was we've talked about
this a bunch of times the machine wasn't
that good at all
but the big advantage they had is they
could see more literally see more could
see things sooner see things better see
things more clearly and make decisions
based on that and how much of a
advantage that was when you said perfect
vision are you talking about the actual
20/20 vision of the pilots if you talked
to those guys back in water or two in
Korea they were guys like the guys were
the most kills they had like twenty ten
yeah all those guys one of the items
they had incredible eyesight literal
vision yeah yeah yeah no that's the
that's why I thought cuz I in Yeager's
book Yeager he talks about how he could
see before anyone else could see he go
we got bogeys or whatever three o'clock
and it would be the game change
absolutely because now you're making
maneuvers
my oldest daughter has 25 vision and
like that when she goes to get her
eyesight checked they bring other people
into the room they're like watch this
yeah but I don't know I don't i think
the generations of a fighter but well it
doesn't really matter that much anymore
right because you got radar it doesn't
that attribute doesn't matter as much
the visual acuity doesn't matter as much
but the principle is exactly the same
it's just what do you what do you see
and you know what you don't see when
you're staring at one thing you know
anything else yeah you know what you see
when you're staring down you're a cog
right you see nothing that's right you
think you see something and you see
absolutely nothing and from a leadership
perspective you're making some big
mistakes back to the book it fosters a
climate where senior leaders know that
their intent will be carried out this
was particularly true for 1st battalion
7th Marines during Operation Desert
Storm as a battalion began breaching
operations for the advance of the 1st
Marine Division across the to the first
two Iraqi mine belts Marines were
suddenly overwhelmed with hundreds upon
hundreds of Iraqi Iraqis supporting
sporting white flags who were trying to
surrender the number was so great that
it threatened to stop the Marine advance
however the battalion commander
immediately recognized the situation
judge that the Iraqis were harmless and
instructive Italian not to stop to
accept their surrender it was precisely
the type of local situation that the
division commander wanted his commanders
to recognize and use their own
initiative to correct here the
commanding officer who was closest to
the situation and who understood the
divisions division commanders intend not
to lose the momentum of the advance
adapted to the situation this adaptation
resulted in the rapid breach of Iraqi
defenses I hope that they rewrite this
book soon and that's a cool example but
the examples that they're gonna get from
Iraq and Afghanistan are gonna be really
awesome too yeah conclusion successful
warfare is filled with examples of
leaders adapting to changing situations
we must start to learn how to adapt now
during our training leaders should value
and encourage innovative thinking
moreover they should expect they should
expect creative thinking from their
subordinates because it creates new
opportunities for adaptation to be
effective commanders must readily
exploit the opportunities uncovered by
subordinates commanders cannot remain
tied to plans that blind them to
fleeting opportunities commanders cannot
remain tied to plans that blind them to
fleeting opportunities while making the
best possible preparations they must
welcome and take advantage of unforeseen
opportunities training now during our
training this was at the last muster I
had a revelation because there's a story
that you talk about when you experienced
a female a belligerent female Iraqi and
basically what would you say she was
doing to you physically moving on you
yep in a non-lethal way but in a way
that was disruptive to what you were
trying to do absolutely and so you are
in a building you're doing a clearance
this was this was really early in your
deployment to our to Ramadi it's my
first mission first mission and tell us
what happened I was on my first mission
the mission was we're gonna clear out an
apartment complex and a main house it
was probably six or seven rooms we was
it just out of curiosity to me got it
yeah good times so we clear out this
room put out all the rooms in the
building and we had essentially
accomplished our primary objective was
just clear everybody out separated the
men and the women to try to figure out
if we could find the guy we're looking
for and they asked me to just go sit in
the main core tree or the main front of
this of this building and just secure
the door are you with an army company or
an army platoon national guard platoon
National Guard is before that guard unit
is there just to just to set this up a
little bit so they're the assault force
they're taking down a building and they
got good deal bathe to go coming with
them and run air support if needed with
your ankle whole team that that's right
first mission I went on these guys have
been there almost a year I want
with him to support with their turns out
when we got inside this building there
were more rooms than they thought so I
had to do some room clearances so I
wasn't expecting it we did it it was
fine then I finished that up and I'm
just sitting in the front open area of
this building thinking everybody is
accounted for everybody's secure down
the stairs probably 20 feet in front of
me an old Iraqi woman she's probably in
her 70s maybe older she's less than five
feet tall she's a tiny little thing and
she is screaming pointing her finger
yelling at me and I'm alone in this room
because we think this room is secure
it's close to the outside so I can talk
to air and she starts coming at me and
she's pointer fingers screaming at me in
Arabic and she's not with her hands but
her body she's so aggressive that she's
I'm backing up she's moving me backwards
and I literally don't know what to do so
I just start backing out up against the
wall and then then how did it conclude
it concluded she got to about I don't
know maybe six or seven feet from me and
over my right shoulder was the entrance
to the outside and the platoon commander
in charge of the whole thing walked in
he either heard it or was just coming
back in to see was going on and he heard
him he came in and he literally just
raised his weapon screamed at her to
stop and and disrupted the situation he
was pretty aggressive and got her to
stop and she stopped that was it there
I was literally doing nothing I was will
you talk about you describe this really
this my little mental repertoire of all
the things I had all the resources of l2
me I was out of ideas I didn't know what
to do no weapon no I did not know what
to do so guess what I didn't do anything
yet so just again cuz cuz this might
seem real obvious when you when you've
got a civilian woman coming at you you
can't you're not gonna shoot her you
don't want a hater like she's 70 years
old and so what are you gonna do how are
you gonna handle the situation it's a
situation you've never been in so the
connection that I made at the last
muster because I was listening you tell
that story and what and I tell a story
about what I would set run training we
hired middle-aged Arabic women to come
and be role players and yell at people
and you know be abrasive and be
aggressive and so why did I do that
because I wanted the guys to be ready
because I knew that that's what's gonna
happen overseas and so it's one of those
things and if
you never seen it before you don't know
what to do and or you may not know you
may not know what to do
whereas all you need to see is at one
time wait a time I guarantee you never
mean you never had a problem again you'd
realize oh this is what this will make
her respond and the solution wasn't that
hard but what you described I
immediately went through my head am I
gonna shoot her no am I gonna hit her no
I went through those those two potential
answers and about a half a second the
answer was no to both there was no third
step in my mind I did not know what else
to do it literally could have been
something if I knew the right word put
my hand up there and took a step towards
her she would have stopped you know but
I didn't know what to do so I didn't do
anything
yeah so that is why the training that
you run as a leader you got to think
about these little things and you might
not think there's plenty of people prior
to us to point to Iraq in 2003 there's
plenty of trainers that would've said oh
you guys all know what to do
no no absolutely they may think they
know what to do and and they might think
the wrong thing as well you know the the
the wrong thing could be oh if you cuz
you can hear people say this hey if
they're gay if they're closing with you
that's a threat you can engage it's like
no that's actually completely wrong it's
actually completely wrong you need to
think about what's going on so the
training that you do and putting people
into situations that they don't expect
and I mean here's the deal man when was
the last time you were on the ground
clearing buildings as a rifleman never I
did a bit of urban training at the base
of school in 1994 for three days so now
this is nine years later eight years
later twelve years oh no 12 years later
12 years later and you're clearing rooms
like TJ Hooker on my first mission yeah
clean rooms and that's what we got to
train for yeah so you got to do that in
the business world too
you got to look and see what can you and
here's what here's the point that I
wanted to make is you might not know to
train somebody for in this specific case
an Arabic woman that's gonna come out to
you I knew that that's what we're gonna
deal with especially once I came back
from
from Ramadi and Baghdad like I knew that
that's where guys are gonna be dealing
with but what situations can you put
them in that just make them think just
make him just make them think that's
what you want to do the truth is what I
didn't need was training to deal with
Iraqi civilians coming at me that's not
the training I needed what I needed to
do was recognize that the chaotic
environment that I'd been in the past
the lessons applied there to I needed to
spend time thinking about what was this
different environment gonna look like
and what did I already knew and
understood could I leverage and that's
what I failed to do had I seen
middle-aged Arabic women in training or
not that's not what I look back and say
that's what I regret for me was not
recognizing I'm gonna be out of my
comfort zone very early on I've been out
of my comfort zone before I have to
remember what that feels like and apply
those same lessons and I could have
handled that situation a million
different ways not because I hadn't seen
the exact same thing before but because
I didn't think about what it's gonna
feel like to be out of my comfort zone
because to be quite honest with you
Jocko it'd been a while since I was out
of my comfort zone in an airplane and I
got pretty complacent with it and I
didn't think about what that was gonna
be like the very next time I I was
carrying a rifle clearing rooms I just
didn't think about it and thank God it
worked out on that first mission because
I cared that with me the rest of the
deployment because believe me I was in a
lot more uncomfortable situations for
this for the next seven months but I
never found myself without understanding
what to do moving forward ever because
of that experience I lucked out on that
one but like you said it applies
everywhere that lesson fits everywhere
in my life in anybody's life yeah all
right next chapter next chapter is
called cooperating again it's important
to note that what we are saying is that
the United States Marine Corps one of if
not the finest whole fighting force that
has ever been on the planet has a entire
chapter about tactics in their book
about tactics there is an entire chapter
that's called cooperating and the
you know I I talk about cooperating all
the time that is one of my laws of
combat I don't call it cooperating I
call the cover move but that's what it
is we are gonna work together that's
what cover move is we are working
together so the importance of working
together the Marine Corps identifies it
they call it something different but
here we go here's a quote unity of
command is coordinated action toward a
common goal
it is cooperation it is working together
by all commanders toward the
accomplishment of a common mission which
is imperative for complete and final
success commanders must develop their
staffs and subordinates the desire to
cooperate not only among themselves but
with other elements of the command and
that's almost an exact quote from when
we talked about cover move not just
amongst your own team but it's with
every team that you're working with that
you need to support or be supported by
in order to accomplish your mission and
that's from tactical principles a navy
manual the other quote gear is the first
element of command and control is people
people who gather information make
decisions take action communicate and
cooperate with one another in the
accomplishment of a common goal and
that's from another Marine Corps pub
called command and control and we
there's there's people that talk about
command or control and we're gonna get
into it just so everyone knows it's okay
you don't need to jump through the
airwaves and come at us because I get
that there's command or control there's
command and control people talk about it
so cover move talking about cooperation
everything that we do everything that we
have to do in tactics gaining advantage
and above all achieving a decisive
result needs a team effort and this is
why when I wrote down the laws of combat
for the first time cover movies first
because if you don't have a team if you
don't have cooperation nothing else it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
have a simple plan it doesn't matter if
you prioritize an execute doesn't matter
if you have decentralized command if you
don't have
teamwork working together it's not gonna
matter if if efforts are not in harmony
results may be indecisive for example if
the aviation combat elements actions are
not harmonized with those of ground
combat element they are likely they are
unlikely to have a decisive effect if
artillery support is not well
coordinated with an infantry attack
combined arms synergy will not be
achieved and the attack may fail however
achieving this team effort is easier
said than done
it requires rapidly maneuvering forces
often widely dispersed to work together
under the most adverse conditions
control in combat because war is
characterized by chaos uncertainty and
rapid change control quickly breaks down
it is probably a mistake to speak of
control in combat think about that right
there think about that right there what
the Marine Corps is saying is if you're
talking about control in combat you're
probably wrong it says it's probably a
mistake unless you're saying control was
almost impossible you shouldn't be
talking about control in combat yeah
guess it's so hard to do I remember the
first times that I was I had I felt the
loss of control this is pretty early
like you go on a raid and you guys
breach the door and they're going in mom
not you I don't have control of that
anymore like they're going whatever
they're in there I can't stop them
anymore I mean I come on the radio and
and and call a call and abort and you
know some of the guys will hear it I can
make up for but like they're going it's
to try and control it is like a is like
a stretch right it's a reach Marine
Corps publication six states that given
the nature of war it is a delusion to
think that we can be in control with any
sort of certitude or precision now look
I'm telling you what is it you if we go
hit a target and there's no bad guys in
there I can control that thing all day
long and everyone - everything's perfect
and all the guys are doing what I told
them to do big micromanager over here
dictating every movement and that'll
work
if but that's not combat right it's a
mission but it's not combat
as anyone next next sentence as anyone
who has experienced combat will
undoubtedly agree it is impossible to
control everything attempts to impose
control also can easily undermine the
initiative upon which the Marine Corps
tactics depend Marines can become
hesitant they may feel like they must
wait for orders before acting we are not
likely to move faster or gain leverage
over a competent opponent unless Marines
at every level exercise initiative the
dilemma then is this how do we achieve
the goal of working together in harmony
while exercising a more decentralized
type of control so there's a little
dichotomy there working together in
harmony but decentralized command at the
same time JP and I were on a call with a
client yesterday and they were talking
about how they need they're very they're
growing rapidly and they've got you know
branches all over the place and what
they need is those branches to start
acting you know on their own they need
to start using decentralized command and
and JP kind of jumped in and said hey
what what is the messaging they're
hearing from you
he said because when he said when I
first got into task unit bruiser this is
JP talking JP when JP first got an
attack tasking a bruiser
he was looking around going like okay
I'm waiting for somebody to tell me what
to do and I was like hey bro you need to
just go do what you think you need to do
as long as it's in line with what like
what we're trying to make happen yeah
and you know I you can imagine JP 21 or
22 years old I remember like the puzzled
kind of curious look on his face when
I'm telling him just because he hadn't
really experienced before like listen I
trust that you are gonna make the right
decision you're gonna make things happen
you when you hear me say break contact
break on you know what to do grab your
fireteam and make it happen when you
hear me say flank I'm not gonna tell you
where to go but you know what you know
what I mean when I say flank
that means I want you to go on a
straight
Berger spooky right now that JP like
that yeah so so that attitude has to
come you have to eat it takes a little
bit of getting used to and people
generally aren't used to it and it takes
a certain level of I don't know what
word use it takes a certain level of
courage to think okay I've never done
I've never just had my boss say yeah
just flank them and gone and flank them
look there's parameters to flanking if
you flank and you move too far you can
get caught off you can move into the
field a friendly feel the fire you can
you can cause some real problems but if
you know what those parameters are you
have free rein to maneuver within those
parameters so so that was a good point
coming from JP to this client like have
you explained to them that listen we are
here we are the central command of
what's going on but we are authorizing
you fully to go out and straight-up make
things happen and that was a that was a
mental jump that JP had to make it
probably took him 15 minutes to make it
because he what he recognized was I just
took the shackles off of his body and
more important I took the shackles off
of his brain to go and just get some and
that's something that you as a leader
have to make sure that you're delivering
that message to the troops so that they
know they can do that and the confidence
it takes a leader to be able to do that
that's significant too because your
natural instinct when you see things
going wrong and receive friction
starting to build is to start to tell
people what to do and this is flat-out
telling you in a lot of cases that's
actually the worst thing you can
possibly do because what will create and
note people doing the work is hesitation
and they'll freeze and they'll look over
their shoulder waiting for your guidance
and that could be a death sentence it's
a death sentence and business as a
Dessen's in combat and it's actually
what we want to do because we think
we're helping I want to I want to get in
there help and it actually takes a ton
of confidence as a leader and you talked
about that feeling of losing control I
remember getting to Ramadi and I had
this vision of how was gonna be as soon
as I got there had to break up my teams
I couldn't operate as a 13 man team
there's too much to do and I remember
probably day three one of my junior
lieutenant or the captain got in his
Humvee with his four guys and drove away
and I was standing there I watched the
vehicle driving like high five go get
some you know and as soon as he left I
and there's a moan of I haven't I won't
talk to him until he comes back
yeah yeah I I did that the same exact
thing we split up into five different
illness and the next thing I know I'm
sending a junior officer a new guy
junior officer that's never been on
deployment before okay he's got an he's
got a v6 with him that's got some
experience but Amen good luck go get
some and that is definitely something
that you have to this is it's hard time
and it's hard going back to the book
cooperation the beginning of the answer
lies in cooperation so the answer that
they're talking about is is how do we
how do we achieve the goal of working
together in harmony while exercising a
more decentralized type of control the
beginning of the answer lies in
cooperation we define cooperation as the
union of self-discipline and initiative
in a pursuit of a common goal
unfortunately they didn't think of the
word dichotomy in the Marine Corps
because that's what they're talking
about the union of self-discipline and
initiative in pursuit of a common goal
cooperation can be viewed as a component
of control control can can generally be
divided into two types centralized and
decentralized centralized control tends
to be one in one direction and works
from the top down someone at a higher
level determines what subordinates will
and will not do centralized control
makes us conform to higher dictates
because one person does the thinking for
the entire organization the person in
control
in contrast decentralized control works
from the bottom up command is exercised
command is the exercise of authority and
guidance and control is felt as feedback
about the effects of action taken
because thinking is required at all
levels feedback allows the commander to
adapt to changing circumstances and to
command subsequent action cooperation is
required in decentralized control
subordinates
together laterally and from the bottom
up to accomplish tasks that fulfill the
commander's intent cooperation means we
take the initiative to help those around
us accomplish our shared mission so
think about what that means is it's it's
saying that the command and control the
definition of control in that
decentralized man is control is control
is bottom-up the control comes up to the
commander not from the commander down
but you know the command the mission
that can be top-down but the control and
how many leaders we work with or that
it's just completely counterintuitive to
how things actually should operate is
the control comes from the bottom from
the point of friction up to the
leadership so they can incorporate all
that and make big picture changes your
team once everyone understands what the
commander's intent is what the broad
guidance is then yes you're you you go
you go and make it happen and the
control the this is where I thought you
were gonna say this what I thought you
were gonna emphasize cuz it is an
amazing statement the control that we
place upon the troops the the control
the what controls them is that they're
working together that's what controls
them is that they're working together so
they can't they what stops them from
going off going off in some other
direction is that they're working
together they're covering and moving for
each other if we don't cover and move
for each other if we decide we're not
gonna cooperate we're not gonna cover
move that means Dave is taking his
element and going somewhere where I can
no longer support you and that can't
happen
so what controls us is that we are
working together our cooperation is what
controls us that's incredible
cooperation is essential to Marine Corps
tactics the flight leader and wingmen
work on the basis of cooperation these
pilots cooperate with the infantry they
support it's just so everyone knows you
could easily just replace these with
cover move the flight leader and the
wingmen work on the basis of cover and
move these pilots cover and move with
the infantry they support two infantry
units fighting side-by-side cover move
for each other a mobile combat service
support detachment and the mechanized
force it supports cover and move
cooperate
we all work together far more
effectively when we communicate
laterally than when we communicate only
through higher headquarters and respond
only to centralized direction as an
ancillary benefit we relieve our
overloaded communication networks so
yeah talk to your peers talk to the
people next to you not just hey I'm
gonna tell the boss on you tell him to
give you some direction work out the
problems amongst yourselves the history
of tactics is filled with examples where
cooperation made the difference and
control could not one such example
occurred during an Iraqi counterattack
in Operation Desert Storm black smoke
from a burning from burning oil wells
turned the day into night a uh-1 huey
pilot used his night-vision equipment to
lead flights of cobras through the near
zero visibility to attack attack high
rocky armored vehicles especially
equipped Huey designated targets so that
the Cobras could engage them at near
point blank range with anti-armor
Hellfire missiles for nearly 10 hours
the Huey pilot led flight after flight
into the pitched battle earning the Navy
Cross for heroism
the pilots worked together to destroy
targets the Huey could not engage and
the Cobra could not see this example
shows what cooperation can accomplish
cover move the next section oddly enough
is called discipline
discipline cooperation can harmonize
efforts and get everyone to work
together without centralized control
that undermines initiative however it
raises a more fundamental question how
do we prepare people to cooperate when
the going gets tough the answer is
discipline there is only one kind of
discipline perfect discipline if you do
not enforce and maintain discipline you
are potential murderers in the face of
adversity and difficulty discipline
enables individuals to pursue what is
best for those around them their unit
and the Marine Corps notice that no part
of that talked about pursuing what is
best for the person themselves visually
a discipline enables individuals to
pursue what is best for those around
them their unit and the Marine Corps
individuals and units might have the
desire but without discipline they will
be unable to accomplish the most
difficult tasks in combat operating
faster than the enemy gaining advantage
generating decisive force and achieving
decisive results in combat instant
obedience to orders is crucial orders
may not be popular but there comes a
point where they must be carried out
without question discipline is a result
of training in training for war
discipline should be firm but fair the
Marine Corps is known as a highly
disciplined fighting force and I got a
pause so that instant obedience to
orders being crucial that's something
that I always have to MMM discuss with
companies with guys in the military with
guys in the teams like what does that
actually mean and there's a whole I mean
it's not that complicated here's the
deal when you see something and you're
being told to do something and it makes
sense you do it and you do it quick
if there's something that is going with
this is a horrible decision that's
coming at you you might need to push
back on that decision up the chain of
command
yes I'm saying that even in the Marine
Corps I'm telling you if if your
being told to enter a building and you
see an IE D in the in the doorway of the
building
you should not instantly o obey this
order that's nuts your boss doesn't want
you to do that your platoon commander
your platoon sergeant does not want you
to do that so the instant obedience to
orders it's it's crucial but we also
need to remember that there is an abroad
order that you've been told right
there's a broad commander's intent the
commander's intent is not to get your
men killed doing something stupid right
the overlying order is hey we're gonna
accomplish this this larger mission and
the tactical call that's being made at
this point in time if it doesn't support
that overall broader mission then you
should not do it now there's a whole
plethora of of situations that can
unfold so if I'm telling Dave to enter
that building and there's an AED in the
and I'm the guy in charge and I'm
telling Dave that there's an AED in the
front yard or I'm telling you to enter a
building and there's an ID in the door
right right and you you tell me no
that's a bad call Jocko I I'm not now
going to say shut up Dave and do what I
told you to do I'm gonna say no we need
you in that building and you're gonna
say look no not a good call you might
not have time to tell me there's an ID
you might just say no not a good call
luckily you and I have built a
relationship of trust where you now when
you tell me you can't do something that
I'm telling you do I know the only
reason possible that you are not doing
what I told you to do is because it is
not possible to do or it's stupid and
then I'm gonna this is this is a weird
thing that I have trouble articulating
now I'm actually gonna go instead of
telling you what to do I'm gonna tell
you why it was I wanted you to do it
hey well what we need is to strongpoint
a building cuz we're getting attacked
and now you look at me okay got that I
can do that I'm in a strong point this
other building over here and you go do
it and then you bring us there so
instant obedience to orders that makes
is true remember that there are broad
orders that you need to follow out now
there could be times where and you know
when you start talking about World War 2
there was times where it's like hey you
need to charge that machine-gun nest and
here's what's gonna happen you charge
that machine-gun nest with your squad
and you're gonna lose half of them right
if you don't do that this whole company
is gonna get killed because we're all
gonna sit here so so so guess what
happens then when you tell me you're
gonna go and I say hey man that's an
elevated bunker position and you look at
me and go listen that's the only way we
get off this Beach then guess what I do
instead obedient to orders and we're
gonna go get it done so this isn't black
and white there you have to think and
these are important there's also a
thread here there's so there's so many
things to talk about you could talk
about this for days but that idea of
perfect discipline that immediate
response to my orders it's built on a
depth and a level of trust that's so
powerful that the obedience isn't out of
fear of not responding to you tell me
what to do the obedience is the
recognition that what he's asking me to
do is actually what's in the best
interest of like um whatever it is this
entire team that we're talking about and
the examples and if you go deep and deep
the stories of guys charging machine
guns nests weren't waiting for the
commander to come down and say charge
the machine gun nests you're actually if
you have that level of trust
you are so far out in front I don't need
jaakor to tell me that because I
actually know you may I know you may
come down to them but I know that's
gonna happen before you come down and
tell me good men get online
we are gonna charge this machine-gun
nest when they're talking about this
this immediate response to orders don't
think of it as you do what I say or this
is the consequence it's gonna happen to
you it's that recognition that what I'm
asking you to do immediately right now
is what is the best interest of
everybody to include you although I
might as a commander you might have to
make that two
I'm gonna there's gonna be loss here I'm
gonna lose some of my men to do that and
that burden of doing that think about
how much trust is required from the
leadership side to cultivate in response
to my suborn its who know their men are
gonna die
and perfect discipline is that
description of there's no other way for
us to be successful unless we do this
and if I actually push back and say no
what I really would like to be able to
do is say no I'm doing this instead
we're just gonna accomplish what you
asked so I don't have to take the time
to talk to you about it in real time
that that come into people think Marine
Corps people follow orders the the
self-discipline that's imposed and those
Marines that that age it only works with
trust up and down the chana command that
is so much more powerful than then that
words can really describe and how
important that is
yeah back to the book the Marine Corps
is known as a highly disciplined
fighting force discipline is one of the
strengths that makes Marines
equally effective assaulting a Beach
conducting conducting a noncombatant
evacuation operation fighting a fire or
guarding our embassies nonetheless
discipline is founded not only on
obedience but also on a sense of duty
the discipline needed for cooperation
comes from two sources imposed
discipline and self discipline the first
source imposed discipline is more often
associated with the term military
discipline imposed discipline typifies
by the Prussian approach is
characterized by instant obedience to
orders external in nature it ensures
compliance with established procedures
rules and guidance and direction from
above it means to achieve efficiency and
accomplishment of routine duties or
drills in its most extreme form it can
be rigid paralyzing and destructive of
initiative imposed discipline also may
make units vulnerable to the effects of
chaos and uncertainty and unable to
cooperate with one another so that idea
that we just talked about that we were
trying to dispel that you and I both
just tried to dispel well they're there
in the process now if dispelling it in
this book
by saying that this this idea of imposed
discipline is is not the kind that we're
talking about impose discipline will
prevent that things you have to do which
is be creative operate in it it's the
thing that undermines what they just
said you have to do is as opposed to
supply and I had to break this out for
young mark in way of the warrior kid
explained the difference between imposed
if discipline and self discipline
carrying on self discipline is an
internal force that morally obligates
all Marines to do what they know is
right in this case to cooperate with
every other Marine in pursuit of a
common goal the obligation is internal
in each individual it is something he or
she feels powerfully about coupled with
a sense of camaraderie in Asprey decor
it pulls from within and causes Marines
to do everything they can for fellow
Marines at the unit level this force can
be felt as morale no system of tactics
can lead to victory when the morale of
an army is bad self discipline can be
seen in successful athletic teams as
well as military units team players
instinctively backup their teammates in
baseball the outfielders cover on fly
balls in hockey rarely does only one
player rush the goal and football
offensive linemen do not stand by idly
on a pass play if no defense or
defensive player faces them they may
block the first defender they can find
they block the first defender they can
find members of squads and fire teams
also work together as teams to
accomplish tasks and take care of each
other this cooperation among teammates
cannot be enforced by a coach or a
leader it depends upon the self
discipline of the individuals marine
discipline is the self discipline of a
successful team not just the imposed
discipline of the army of Frederick the
Great for Marines military discipline
means accepting personal responsibility
I think I wrote a book called extreme
leadership self-discipline will not
allow us to shirk responsibility or
blame others I think a book called
extreme ownership a discipline failure
often a failure to act is a personal
failure our form of discipline is also
absolute there is no time off someone
else may be in charge but that does not
absolve us from the responsibility to to
do everything we can to achieve the
common goal it does not reduce our
responsibility to cooperate with fellow
Marines in our unit and beyond this
discipline is a mindset a way of
thinking and behaving it runs through
everything that we do it is much a part
of Garrison life as of combat
we also carry this sense of personal
responsibility and duty to contribute
into our private lives we see it
whenever off-duty Marines take the
initiative to help at the scene of an
accident act as leaders in their
communities or in other ways do more
than their share they do so because of
something inward not because they are
compelled by control
that's something is self-discipline and
it is not limited to one aspect of life
check those two pages man our it is so
succinct and so straightforward the way
they describe what marine discipline is
and where to place all the time
everywhere without exception and you
were a wholly responsible for the
success of everybody else around you
based on your individual individual
actions and that applies everywhere in
your life it took me three books to
explain that yeah
just crystal clear crystal clear it
concludes here modern tactics rely on
cooperation cooperation in turn depends
on discipline discipline consists of
both imposed discipline and self
discipline as leaders of Marines we must
create a climate in which self
discipline and a high level of
initiative can flourish within the
boundaries of military discipline
there's the dichotomy right there
initiative can flourish within the
boundaries of military discipline that's
what you want you know I always use the
word parameters one of them - what I'm
talking about decentralized command like
as long when when I give you the
parameters do whatever you want inside
those parameters that's what they're
talking about you do whatever you want
within the boundaries of military
discipline this climate depends on us
words are easy anyone can give an
occasional pep talk on the merits of
self discipline Marines judge actions
not words and respond positively by
leadership to leadership by example if
the leader creates a climate where
perfect discipline is expected and
demonstrated cooperation will follow
him discipline is always a good note to
end on actions not word not words create
discipline so that was two more chapters
what do we do not bad a little shorter
two more chapters we got two more to go
and we'll dig under into those on the
next podcasts discipline once again
something that we hear a lot about
something that I talk about a lot the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
I'm glad I wrote that when I did because
it would be hard for me to write it
right now and not just say hey just go
read this book discipline is a critical
factor in it allows us to win on the
battlefield and it allows us to really
win everywhere in health in business in
Fitness and jiu-jitsu in life you gotta
got to maintain the discipline yes echo
Charles yes speaking of discipline now
that you are back from your highly
undisciplined vacation well you know why
mm-hmm is that is that wrong yes that is
wrong oh you were highly disciplined
quasi quasi not kind of you know here
and there you know that was a thing I
don't think that is a thing I think in
my world is not a thing actually
technically I think that's a counter
well Dave is it each sections on quasi
there's only one kind of discipline and
it's not quasi it's not quite the quasi
kind of makes it an equated or either
you discipline or not discipline right
yeah in fact quasi discipline is
essentially undisciplined that's what I
okay so you see where I'm coming from
yeah your trip to Hawaii was essentially
unless if we're not quasi dissing yeah
now maybe some moments of discipline
yeah for sure you made you did some work
did some work did some training did some
train some of the digits no oh that's
dangerous but I saw some jujitsu guys so
you know that's something all right well
since the rest of us are trying to
maintain our discipline you have any
recommendations yeah now we can't be
able to do that yeah we'll talk about
jujitsu that's a good way to maintain
discipline so juice is one of those
what'd he call you could call it a
dichotomy because you have to have
discipline to do jujitsu and jujitsu
will kind of give you discipline Oh
it'll be prompt I'm not you're gonna say
if you do judges you're gonna have to
have creativity this that do for sure
super oh yeah full-on metaphor for life
in fact good deal Dave Burke you're
talking about you know in the airplane
right how do you close the distance or
whatever so jiu-jitsu is one of those
things when you first learn self-defense
especially from the Gracie that Gracie
way it's like there's three zones is the
green zone which is like you're out of
range essentially then there's the other
green zone when you're like too close
because you can't take effective punches
all the same thing right then there's
that red zone so when you find yourself
in your kid when you're what you're
talking about when you find yourself in
that red zone kind of you know were you
better react you go to one of the green
zones in a plane obviously to get to the
far green zone is gonna take way more
time so it doesn't seem like the logical
thing and you're a huge risk yes you try
and get to the far degrees now yeah it's
like unrealistic in fact you got to
essentially travel through the whole red
zone to get to that great same thing
with jiu-jitsu if you're in the red zone
then again I mean it's easier to get out
of distance than it would in a fighting
situation that would be an airplane I
know you got it right there's there's
layer there's boundaries there and at
different places you'll do different
things that thing I describe doesn't
apply if you're at 25 miles away you
have discs different responses you're
spot-on man
so on both of them to get too close to
be in range is the safe thing to do it's
not as intuitive you know like if I can
run yeah yeah but you got to be on 25
miles to be able to write if I - you got
a well you
have to know where you are it may be in
a fight three feet or but there's a
range and you have to know if you're
inside or outside that range whatever
the range is it's certainly different
than an airplane than in two people
fighting but you actually know where you
are because if you make a decision
inside of that range you'll get yourself
killed if you try to run in an airplane
and you're the place where you can't
you'll die period no different and if
you're inside that range and you try to
close the distance that will actually
keep you alive by getting closer you
just have to know where you are yeah and
when you're untrained it doesn't seem
that obvious because when I'm to look
I'm fighting with Dave Burke he's
punching me in the face
my first instinct isn't to go towards
those punches to the inside you see them
saying I mean although they're they're
definitely that kind of is an instinct
or is that a training thing nah man get
a punch an untrained person in the face
there you not only are they gonna go
away they're gonna turn away they're
gonna turn their back they're gonna run
away just instinctually yeah for sure
but if there's some training or whatever
then yes you see in the cage or in the
ring as soon as someone starts getting
hit they know that they need to get
close yeah that's fully trained
occasionally you'll see someone trying
to run away even in the cage you mean in
MMA actual fight someone will try and
get away yeah occasionally yeah but
either way the guy who goes in and
closes the distance when they're in
trouble that's a trained person yeah
hundred percent 100 percent 100 percent
instinctive a declaration okay that
number you were talking 90 something
percent high really seriously it's high
I think hundred percent off the bat yeah
you couldn't because I think untrained
yeah yeah ever name that's true who did
because I'm thinking because what I'm
thinking of is like oh you got some kid
that wrestled for two years in junior
high school when he starts getting hit
he could very well close missiles yeah
train but he's tried yet oh good point
then again what do I know that's what it
seems like isn't it weird that your your
intuition could be just wrong yeah
because they're specific you heard that
a lot in jujitsu like in jujitsu you go
man this was a bad decision I just made
yeah it seemed like a good idea it was
not yeah I would think that like in like
the natural world that the intuition is
gonna be correct
that's what I think but I'm saying it's
not that's what I'm saying
no but
but it's not when you're dealing with
trained individuals like basically
manufactured scenarios you know and
however chaotic the scenario is you're
saying you take two humans that grew up
on deserted Islands with you know held
yeah wild yeah Dave starts like being
aggressive towards me in one or another
where it makes me uncomfortable oh I'm
leaving 100% even if he doesn't even
throw punches he just starts getting a
gret oh I'm leaving
really mmm what do you go fight or
flight right flight is like one of him
he starts punching in the face lawn
leaving I can get away from those
punches or whatever but if he's trained
or or if he knows I'm gonna leave ooh
there it becomes the training so you're
saying I'm trained I know he's gonna
leave for something I've been through
that experience I'm saying yeah I just
know that sometimes my instincts are
really bad boy am I to probably like 99%
of the time jack unless ya take
jiu-jitsu you will get good instincts
trained into you because they become
instinctive yeah you know ingrained into
you there's nothing better you know what
I have an instinct for and I don't mean
this to be I'm not trying to attack you
right now like verbally that means my
thing instinct is to grab you in a
guillotine like my hand just goes there
yeah I do not all one or training yeah
yeah yeah yeah like more training for
real I just have you in a guillotine I'm
like boo boo were rolling and they're
home yeah I don't know what happened
boom got you in a guillotine yeah well
I'm not saying you're gonna tap but I'm
saying it to there yes I agree yeah that
is one of the things for sure
nonetheless when everyone starts to Jiu
Jitsu they're gonna need what Aggie
Aggie a rash guard and the desire to
Train really that's what it comes down
to oh and a place to Train and people to
train with essentially as you can that's
the big man from jujitsu you need
another human yes but as far as the keys
in the rash guards what kind of gives
you gonna get because that's still a
question it's still a question this
shouldn't be way less prevalent now but
if you don't know you get an origin key
where do you get em from origin main
dot-com Dave Burke you have an Origin
key I have to origin keys
I use them all the time any bees do you
have to that one that used the phrase
100% and that applies to the number of
keys that I have well good get some rash
guards in there as well those are good
ones also jeans denim yeah
American denim innate in America made by
the team up in Maine yeah yeah those are
good surprisingly fashionable not overly
fashionable mmm that would be a that
would be a horrible thing yeah yeah oh
if we started venturing into well then
that that would have to come from Pete
who can be a little bit more overly
fashionable here's the thing about Pete
though he's from Maine so Maine is not
exactly the fashion hub of the
University not exactly I'm not like you
know this barraging his fashion sense
I'm not my relative to the world
relative to LA New York and Paris yeah
you go right in the middle of Paris yes
and you say hey guys Pete has no
reference if he's in Paris is what I'm
hearing correct yes that is but in
Farmington Maine he's kind of recently
kind of stylish yes yeah which to me is
perfect yeah it winds up to be perfect
cuz it's on the mild in my house he's
like straight from Paris like a guy from
Paris you're a guy from New York yeah
and then he's walking off the catwalk
into my living room that's what I see
you know well you got the jeans so boom
here in that I'm saying
luckily the jeans are are there they're
functional is the deal yeah that's
straight functional and chocolate you
look good in them let's face it I'm not
over here looking at me or other people
I'm looking at you right you're the man
hey I've got a bunch of other stuff on
their t-shirts joggers which echo likes
I I cannot wear joggers yeah that's too
far for you 100% and and then there's
also supplements chocos so Dave how does
your daughter like how does your oldest
daughter like strawberry milk
it's funny you asked we were actually
talking about this the other day I was
describing on the last podcast how good
strawberry milk tasted and I was trying
to use find the right words so I give my
son strawberry milk mmm because he's
he's five five yep
he likes milk it's good for him yeah you
know he's got a bit of a sweet tooth so
we're not doing nestle quicker than that
crap we don't do it so Oh cause you
don't want to poison your own children
no I don't love my kids and I don't want
to poison them and they don't have that
as a friend he's never had it so he
doesn't know he just knows the stuff
tastes good my daughter my oldest
daughter snagged took the bottle from
him slid it off the table towards her I
was sitting across from her
we weren't talking I just watching her
she took the bottle drank a sip of his
strawberry milk and she closed her eyes
and looked up at the sky with her eyes
closed and just said to her to herself
it's so that's and I'm like that's what
I knew that that's how I feel about
strawberry milk is what she said to
herself about how good it is
yeah and the strawberry seems to be too
many people kind of the the the top of
the taste pyramid I will say this though
I can go to strawberries maybe 300 now I
did go on like a full-on strawberry
rampage when it first came out you're
talking about the adult we don'twe the
kids what is delicious too but the the
adult strawberry milk I went on like a
three-week rampage of just strawberry
and now I'm back to it's in the rotation
it's it's like two strawberries mint
strawberry peanut butter I'm probably a
month behind
I think I got I got about a month behind
you okay so you're just so actually
today on the way here I went back to
mint had a double scoop of mint on the
way hand with bellus Cooper hitter
and I was reminded yeah it was so good
so I have finally just come off the
exclusive strawberry train yeah
nice strawberry still good to go oh yeah
I was reminded of how good the mint was
today you know what the cool thing is
this isn't like being married you need
to get married to strawberry like okay
the strawberry tastes good
but you can still just get that meant
back on if you want to get that only if
it's get that little peanut butter yeah
the one scoop Peter if you get the one
scoop peanut butter I'm talking that
thing is just a little bit of dead petal
tide you over so that's the milk you can
get some of that mole discipline go this
you Dave each time you've come on this
podcast the past three straight podcasts
I see you do a little something blows a
little ritualistic scenario going on
over there before you you put something
in your mouth you swallow it what is
that all about
that's the the discipline go to prep me
for having my head in the game which I
want on this podcast actually I want to
be in the game all the time to be honest
with you I can't think of any place
where I don't want to really be in the
game other than getting ready to go to
bed yeah so the discipline go pills if
I'm gonna do something that requires me
to think I'm taking yeah to include this
podcast yeah it's it you can feel it
without question you can feel it but
it's it's subtle to it doesn't like it's
not like getting hit in the head with a
hammer it's it's a it's a subtle get you
up on the step and you look and you're
like oh I'm in the game and you can feel
that you're in the game there but it
wasn't like a big shock to the system it
gets you up there subtly and then you're
there and actually you can stay there
for a while yeah what I look as you look
around like two hours later and you're
like yeah this would be ah I'm on fire
and you're like oh yeah yeah that's
that's right that's what just happened
yep yeah you mention the warrior kid
milk so there's the warrior kid milk and
then we have chocolate tea which is you
know summertime just when I got the cans
they're just sitting around my house
they're in the fridge or just getting
pulled out my whole family's just
cracking out on jakka white tea so give
that a try and don't forget the joint
warfare and krill oil big part see see
even how you're just like oh yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah like yeah it's just so
that's a given yeah
think it is a given - that's another one
sorry I mean if you're working out which
we are the tone in my voice was actually
like apologetic to the world that's
right yeah yeah yeah like I can't
believe I forgot that yeah because if
you're not doing that the reason why the
reason why I can forget it is because
when I brush my teeth in the morning
yeah I'm taking John Warren when I brush
my teeth at night and floss enjoy more
fur and I'm taking krill oil yeah so
that's just that's just how that's just
house - saying Hawaii
oh yeah hundred percent but some people
maybe they don't know you know maybe I
think most of us do but yes let's not
forget that that's the point krill oil
joint warfare keep yourself physically
in the game so you can do whatever live
left did you get to boom oh yeah
I'm just saying lifting that you're
taking it for granted
yeah I got back into back squats by the
way laying down in bed with my wife
that's right I said it and she even said
like your legs look big right now she
didn't know I got back into back squat
what'd she say about your uh anyway yes
are outstanding and yeah keep yourself
in the game get in the game keep
yourself in the game that's how also we
have our own store it's called Chacko
store just like you mentioned choco
store calm this is where you can get the
rash guards t-shirts gonna represent
while you're on the path this is where
you can get this stuff the merch there's
a word my daughter keeps saying that you
know your daughter is only six years old
yes sir I know
and then she's saying merch cuz she
watches these YouTube videos and they're
like oh gosh the merch and I'm like it's
kind of the thing is you know how you're
so biased towards your kids well I am I
don't know about you but and they say
something like kind of wack and you're
like oh that's so cute I'm in that boat
right now
oh with the we don't recognize that it's
not cool correct
okay not yet nonetheless if you want
merch jaw closed or calm truckers hats
you know be nice yes hoodies hoodies
lightweight and Dave Burke's here yeah
lightweight hoodie approved when we're
at is how like he really to me oh yeah
big time
my little brother Kenyatta Charles
that's his name by the way lives on
Hawaii he went out of his way to tell me
that that like Hawaii I understand which
is more like that like what would you do
with a full weight hoodie in Hawaii yeah
be a better cover nah man days are not
back Dave lives in San Diego even that
so here's the thing your how about my
people up in Michigan it would be
obvious if he was talking only about the
functionality of it but he was talking
about everything the feel the fit the
look good ladies also subscribe to this
podcast if you haven't already because
echo thinks you might not have and then
don't forget about the warrior kid
podcast that one you could forget to cuz
I haven't put it out as often as I
should yeah
but I should put it out more a lot of
parents just have the warrior kid
podcast on Ricky
repeat Dave do the lessons sink in from
the warrior kid podcast they do I have
learned that my kids understand more
than I thought they would understand
because I watch how they react to the
lessons I learned the podcast and the
books they sink in if you want to get
some soap get it from Irish Oaks ranch
calm because there's a young warrior kid
named Aiden who's living on a farm and
he's making soap from goat milk mmm
choco soap and if you use that soap you
can stay clean and don't forget about
our YouTube channel because echo wants
you to watch the videos that he makes
and he's super excited and thinks that
they look cool he's like the Paris of
moviemaking someone just that ro someone
tightened you up on one of your little
little excerpt like hey podcast number
180 whatever is up and someone wrote
music was a little much yeah I was like
D hey coming off the top rope oh that's
a little crazy right well one it's a
fifty two second videos not even one
minute and someone said echoes news
a little much yeah well you know I am
used to that comment because let's face
it sometimes man it is it is a little
much I get it it's true but at the same
time it depends on what he meant overall
like a little what little too loud or
was it is no choice is like too dramatic
or the fact that there's music at all I
know there's too dramatic did you get
much the cello players of the world are
real appreciative of your musical taste
did they break out the cellos and you
break out the recorder so yeah if you
want to check out little excerpts of
this get get the you choose you know
subscribe to it smash the link but I
know Dave psychological warfare do you
ever have to press play on psychological
warfare unfortunately once in a blue
moon yeah I've got it down pretty good
at this point I have I have what I call
psychological warfare in my head yeah I
kind of know what you're gonna say at
this point so the reality is is I don't
need that resource because it's it's
there permanently embedded yeah I know
what you're gonna say at this point yeah
and that's a good point because it's
like it's one thing to like listen to it
let's say for the first second third
time or whatever and it's like oh yeah
you're right you're right and you're
fired up to sort of do it but at the
same time you're not just getting like
jockle like hate to say it like
motivating you to do it you're
motivating you with logic don't get it
wrong but you still arguing motivate do
after a while that actual logic gets
embedded in your head no that's the
transition from imposed discipline to
self-disclose yeah right there you know
the best you do you know like oh hey
yeah like you don't feel like doing it
but you know you're supposed to do it
you know how you're gonna feel
afterwards then you know the results and
the thing is that's a fact so you get
reminded of it so many times how ever
many times you listen to it then you're
kind of like yeah I kind of know that so
you can essentially tell yourself that
yes yeah so if you want that it's on
iTunes Google Play mp3 flipside canvas
if you want a visual reminder of the
path go to flipside campus.com my
brother Dakota Meyer running that
making art tag on your walls with lair
with layers multiple layers oh yeah big
time
also on it on it calm slash choco by the
way this is where you can get fitness
gear some good I have this electrolyte
supplement that I get it's like a go-to
by the way it's like electrolyte
minerals and whatnot anyway get it from
on it and so the rings that you so
strongly how should I say recommended
early on mm-hmm
came in handy so I brought them to my
trip to COI yeah here's the thing about
those rings though you have to kind of
think ahead on where to hang them
it's not that hard it's fine I know I
know but I found myself in a situation
where I'm like searching you can't just
hang them from the ceiling fan you you
guys have to go find a corner annual
adaptation yeah previously anticipating
even if you got a hang them from a tree
but nonetheless the point is it's not
like a squat you can't just bring the
squat rack took quiet with you
you see I'm saying you gotta go to quite
a sequin out or something like that but
the Rings they go with you both from in
the suitcase carry carry literally carry
the Rings on the plane whatever it's so
it's easy you know and then you can get
yeah that work out not to mention the
workouts from rings are gonna be a lot
better than if you don't have ring
anyway get get there's a lot of stuff
good kettle bells on their decorative
artistic kettle bells on that that's
what I get my um a lot of good stuff on
there on it calm slash
got a bunch of books where the warrior
Kid three where there's a wall where
there's a will that is live and it's
actually available on Kindle right now
we just released the Kindle version so
apologize it took a little longer way
the warrior Kid one and then way the
warrior Kid 2 marks mission that is
where you can get your kids on the path
miking the dragons for anyone that needs
to overcome fear face fear get miking
the dragons discipline equals freedom
Field Manual this is the adult version
of how to get after it
and then there's extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership which are
books that I wrote with my brother life
babban they are the combat leadership
lessons we learned and how you can apply
them
your life and your business we got a
salon front which is where we solve
problems through leadership leadership
consultancy if you want myself if you
want Dave Burke if you want
Lafe babban JP Danelle if you want flynn
cochran if you want Jason Gardner if you
want Mike Cirelli to come to your
location and help you align the
leadership in your organization who time
is Mike bimah if you want anyone from
echelon front go - Ilan front comm
that's what we do
we solve problems through leadership and
we got EF online which is online
interactive training because leadership
training of any kind is not an
inoculation you need to get booster
shots and that's what EF online is and
it's something that you can put through
your whole organization get your whole
organization from the frontline troops
to the senior leadership on the same
path with leadership EF online.com
we got the muster the muster is coming
up in September 19th and 20th in Denver
it's almost sold out so if you want to
come you better just register ASAP
Sydney Australia and December 4th and
5th go to extreme ownership calm every
one of them have sold out and those will
sell out - and then of course EF
overwatch which we're taking combat
leaders from Special Operations from
combat aviation guys like Dave Burke
good deal Dave yes guys with that kind
of experience and we are placing them
into we're placing them into civilian
companies where they are using their
leadership that they learned that
they've been tested on and putting it to
work in the civilian world of course you
can't have Dave Burke because Dave Burke
is with us on the team at Ashkelon front
and echo you got anything else don't
good to see Dave Burke here share time
and space with them other than that no
man carry on
check Dave
nothing to add check and if you do have
something to add out there that's fine
there's still a chance you can find us
on the interwebs we are on Twitter
Instagram and the Safra zine walking
that goes that echo Charlie Dave is that
Dave David are Burke ber ke and I am at
Jocko willing and we have been getting
granular with the Marine Corps right now
but we certainly honor all the branches
of the military Army Navy Air Force
Marines Coast Guard including
active-duty reservists Guard units and
all the vets thanks to all of you for
allowing us the freedom to record this
podcast and to live the lives that we
live in to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol Secret Service all the first
responders out there thanks to you all
as well for being there for us when it
counts when we need you to keep us safe
you are there standing by and we
appreciate it and to everyone else out
there remember what the Marine Corps
says about discipline discipline is
absolute
there is no quasi discipline there is no
time off discipline is a way of thinking
and more important than a way of
thinking discipline is a way of behaving
it is about actions not words so don't
allow any slack
instead take charge take action seize
the initiative and get after it and
until next time this is Jocko and echo
and Dave out